[Music]
baby photos are always adorable and
there's no exception when it comes to
the characters in Hotel Transylvania 3
watch until the end to see Dracula as a
baby if this is your first time visiting
the things don't forget to subscribe and
please give this video a big thumbs up
here's Hotel Transylvania 3 as babies
baby Mavis Mavis was born to her vampire
parents Dracula and Martha in 1894 in
Transylvania after her mother died she
lived with her father and they moved to
the newly constructed Hotel Transylvania
jocular wanted to stay there forever to
make sure Mavis stays safe and you will
understand why after seeing ruth who
misers work on deviantart of her as a
baby little Mavis as illustrated by
Powermaster fourteens work on deviance
art still has the same big blue eyes and
expressive eyebrows as she becomes a
toddler we can see her fangs starting to
grow but her wonder and amazement with
the world around her definitely
foreshadows her future desire for
independence
this little baby sure has the attitude
and spunk be recognized in adult Mavis
baby Erica van Helsing we meet Erica in
Hotel Transylvania 3 along with Dracula
who immediately starts crushing on the
luxury cruise ship though Erica is
attractive and charming she has a dark
past that causes Mavis to become
concerned with her father's feelings for
Erica there is something about that
woman I don't trust turns out Erica is
related to Hahn the monster hunter and
Dracula's enemy however Erica never knew
her parents and was raised by her
grandparents as a child she was taken
around the world on her
great-grandfather ship she was a very
determined and impressionable baby who
knew what she wanted to carry on her
family's legacy baby Frank Frank is a
great best friend - Dracula and a caring
loving uncle - Mavis he is married to
Eunice and is a true gentle giant though
he can be unpredictable he also hates
and fears fire Frank met Dracula as an
adult but as a baby he would have been
far away from flames and probably
stumbling over his big monster feet his
nice and kind smile shows that Frank has
always been well-intentioned and loyal
to the ones who loves a baby Frank is
floating in a green substance with a
skeptical look on his face child Vlad
seeing as Vlad is one thousand two
hundred and fifty-one years old
not much is known about his childhood
other than the fact that he was once
married and had a son with Dracula he
puts a lot of importance on being a
monster with monster family members when
he see those fangs he was definitely not
pleased to find out that Dennis his
great-grandson is only half monster
nevertheless black comes around which is
why we're sure this blue-eyed young bat
would have been easygoing as a baby as
an adamant vampire we're sure Youngblood
enjoyed his hunting sprees young unis
unis is Frank's wife Anne's burrow
monster she's got some pretty on point
style Eunice really reinforced Dracula's
believe that Mavis should be kept safe
in the hotel secluded from any humans
Eunice is unapologetic and always
worried but she's also fun her outfit
alone with her pink fluffy turtleneck
hoop earrings and tight skirt emphasize
her confident personality as a baby and
Alex Alyssa's sketch baby tears Eunice
has the same white streak in her hair
but she's a lot funnier Eunice was a
secure and happy baby that grew into the
woman who wants to be able to see Mavis
have a similar happy worryfree
upbringing baby Jonathan Jonathan
stirred up a lot of commotion when it
was revealed that he was actually a
human disguised as a monster
nevertheless there's something to be
said about all the trouble this
character was willing to go to in order
to be accepted by his vampire
girlfriend's family Jonathan is easy to
imagine as a baby because dennis is a
splitting image of him red hair and all
night lights deviantART drawing looks
like Jonathan's baby picture with the
same goofy innocence and wild red hair
he's even wearing an oversized t-shirt
that hints at his grown-up baggy style
grasping for his toes it's clear that
this baby will be a go-getter and will
fight for what he believes in the baby
Murray Murray is always happy to be the
life of the party when he shows
he spends most of his time inside an
Egyptian tomb
he's another fun-loving monster who's a
very close friend of Dracula he's always
there for the important moments and
doesn't get wrapped up in any
unnecessary drama as a baby
Murray's raps were cleaner and much
whiter he definitely gained some weight
over the course of the past hundreds of
years despite a threatening exterior to
those glowing eyes young Murray was just
as silly and ready to have fun
clearly he's been snacking on too much
candy as his teeth have also rotted
weighing the pup Wayne struggles with
his job as data processor by day though
he's a family man who cares about his
wife Wanda and his children he's
generally stressed out he loves being
with his best friends at the hotel
though there's definitely wear with
blood in EM EE me 3 4 5 s deviantART
post of baby where whoo-hoo we can see
Wayne's already happy to have to kill
prey to quench his hunger as seen by his
skull bib still dressed in blue this pup
already has his older disposition of
feeling exasperated and fed up as he
rolls his eyes this cute little guy
should behave instead of giving his
parents the same grief his children will
eventually give him Dennis Dennis the
half vampire son of Mavis and Jonathan
he is already pretty young but that one
red hair curl on top of his head as a
gummy baby is just too cute / words
combine it with his big blue eyes and
his huge ears it's clear to see that
this baby is a younger Dennis on his
fifth birthday he grows his fangs and
his vampire abilities start to kick in
Dennis has run two characters whose
growth is probably the most obvious in
the movies as he goes from being a bit
of a shy and nervous kid to a spunky
adventurous and energetic half-human
Baby Dracula Dracula lives to have
everything under control
especially his family safety having
accepted his human son-in-law reconciled
with his dad and embraced his half
vampire son Hotel Transylvania 3 is his
shot to focus on himself
Vlad had to resort to fear tactics in
hopes of getting Dracula his son to grow
his fangs because he was a late bloomer
oh he's a late fanger just like you this
resulted in a melancholy baby Dracula
and this picture for
second brush calm of him is in black and
red baggy pajamas it is just too cute
for words he still has his pointed
widow's peak nose and ears that make him
look like a typical vampire and that's
it for Hotel Transylvania 3 as babies if
this is your first time visiting the
things don't forget to subscribe and
please give this video a big thumbs up
[Music]